some uber drivers are concerned the
company's lucrative incentives are
pushing them to sacrifice sleep for more
pay
uber is in the first month of its
six-month program designed to help
drivers make more money the 180 days of
change calls for tipping shorter
cancellation windows and no more unpaid
wait time but some drivers say they
still cannot make a decent wage without
getting the bonuses they client they
claim require longer hours and less
sleep John Blackstone wrote along with
an uber driver in San Francisco John
John our labor driver Dan Kerrigan says
he was making a lot more money a few
years ago but with fares dropping to
lure customers he says now it's the
drivers who are getting taken for a ride
there's so many people believe that you
can just hop in the car and drive when
you want you're gonna make what you need
you're not gonna make what you need
unless you make the bonus uber says the
incentives are simply designed to help
drivers earn extra money for instance if
drivers take ten trips between 9:00 p.m.
and midnight on a Friday they could get
an extra $20 but Carrigan says with
fares dropping the optional bonus has
become mandatory one ride short you lose
a third of your income more so for one
ride you'd say I'm pretty late at night
oh yeah I would definitely stay up later
at night if I was that close to the
bonus I would push myself past the point
of me being tired the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration estimates
there could be as many as 1.2 million
collisions every year because of drowsy
driving still there's no clear data on
how many of those might have involved
ride-hailing service drivers ubers app
reminds drivers to rest but the company
does not set a cap on their hours rival
lyft shuts off its app after drivers
work more than 14 hours requiring a six
hour break but that's voluntary because
hours for ride sharing service drivers
are not federally regulated they have no
responsibility because they've
completely delegated the safety of the
driver and of the passengers to the
driver himself or herself
uber estimates that just seven percent
of drivers work more than 50 hours per
week while more than half of drivers in
the US
use the uber app less than ten hours a
week still for the rest getting enough
rest could sometimes be a challenge
strong coffee and Red Bull a big part of
being a Hoover driver these days
coffee for sure for CBS this morning
John Blackstone San Francisco you make a
good point I mean they are making the
choice to keep driving but if they need
to make a living you're also domani make
a living yeah I like the idea of the app
shutting down after X amount of hours
because when you're tired driving tired
is just as damaging as driving when
you're under the influence or safe but
then you could just go try for a
different half right that's right